[音楽]
ん
r 5
4日
[音楽]
ん
うんうん
ある日の話です
私はいつものように
郵便遊戯に郵便物がないかと思い
犬館まで行ったところ
ええええええ
私には
全く身に覚えのない
[音楽]
となる風潮が入っていました
住所が完全に私はてねラリー
私に向けられた郵便物であることは間違いないと思い
その郵便物
受け取ることにしたのです
ですが
やはり私には右覚えがなく
この封筒を開けるか
とても迷ったのです
私はふうと当ててしまいました
はぁっ
ボンッ
ん
恨むと書かれた本が入っていました
とても驚きましたが
私はなぜか
取り憑かれたように
訪問を読みまくったのです
カナダかっに動いてしまいましたですが著作現場中身は見せられません申し訳ないです
方
飲むことは止まることを知らず3つ付けました
[音楽]
んまぁまぁそこそこ強かったです
風洞の中には1枚の紙が入っていました
ん
加護と初めこれは完全に私の名前
this が私の苗字が間違っていました私は白の間に何者かの手によって
foma メンバーにされてしまっており
メルマガ会員になっていましたはぁ
ん
なんだろうこれ
何ね大画面バーツって言っ
なんだよ見れば図鑑いて
ん
誰だよこんなの仮定したやつや恐怖
びっくりっ
肥満が私は遅い
もうのメンバーについて
ネットで調べまくった結果
達事実を知ってしまったのです
[音楽]
よかったん
me
teame
teal
me
ana あああっ